Sometimes, it’s the details of a film that
matter most.
Like… a single shot… a needle drop…
— “I see a little silhouette of-“ — a
line of dialogue…
— “Here’s lookin’ at you, kid.”
— a sudden cut…
What seem like insignificant choices often
say more in under twenty seconds than other
films say in two hours.
In this new format, we’ll be studying these
seemingly trivial pieces, revealing how even
the smallest element can bring layers of meaning
to a piece of art.
Welcome to Wisecrack’s THE FILM TOURIST:
The Wolf of Wall Street.
“Sell me this pen!
Sell me… this pen.”
The closing shot of The Wolf of Wall Street.
“This pen works…”
Just a simple push-in and crane-up.
Well… what if I told you this shot changes
the meaning of the entire film?
“This pen works, and I personally love—“
As a client describes ‘the pen’, his voice
drowns out and solemn music kicks in.
Up to this point, the film has utilized poppy,
upbeat hits to underscore the debauchery.
“The amnesia phase.”
So, why the sudden shift to something more
serious and meditative?
For most of its three-hour runtime, The Wolf
of Wall Street revels in Jordan Belfort’s
excess: his yacht, his women, his drugs, his
parties -- the lifestyle paid for by defrauding
investors.
That is, until the FBI circles in, seizing
Belfort’s cash and sending him away to prison
for four years.
But unlike similar films— where, the corrupt
Wall Street broker gets locked up and justice
is served — The Wolf of Wall Street is absent
any overt moralizing.
Belfort’s prison sentence is a cakewalk,
and he doesn’t even serve his full sentence.
In the end, nothing has changed.
Belfort is still selling and the people, well,
they’re still buying.
But this is just the tip of the iceberg.
The final shot can be interpreted in a number
of ways, but here are our three favorites.
One: the final shot holds up a mirror to us,
the moviegoers viewing the film.
Notice there’s a backlight behind the seminar
that evokes a projector shining on the back
of an audience.
So, what does this mean?
Well, it may to easy to lay the blame solely
on Jordan for all the moral depravity in The
Wolf of Wall Street.
“Jordan!” “Jordan, Jordan, listen!”
“Jordan?
Jordan?”
“Jordan!” “Jordan!”
“You!”
But, perhaps the final shot lays the blame
not only on Belfort, but on us, and the culture
that allows and encourages his behavior.
“My wife might divorce me but, yeah, let’s
do it.”
Early on, Belfort says, “Every person you’re
on the phone with, they want to get rich and
they want to get rich quickly.
They all want something for nothing.”
We may feel dignified because we’re not
crawling on the ground f**ked up on quaaludes,
but truth is, Jordan’s scam wouldn’t work
if we didn’t share his dream of getting
rich quickly.
Wanting something for nothing…
We all want to be just like him.
Scorsese is essentially calling us out - we’ve
just spent three hours partying with Jordan,
laughing and reveling in his exploits.
It’s no wonder Jordan doesn’t suffer any
punishment in the end, because, after all,
we revel in everything he does, living vicariously
through him, wishing that we could live his
life.
Two: do all these people staring intently
at one person, hanging on his every word remind
you of something?
Yeah, we’re gonna go there.
Scorsese, a devout catholic, has spent much
of his career exploring his faith in films.
Yet, in The Wolf of Wall Street characters
worship at the altar of something else: MONEY.
The camera holds on these people: each one
in focus so we can see their painfully average
faces — desperate, plain-looking people
looking for meaning; desiring that which can
elevate them above their mundane existence.
Is Scorcese cynically likening the transformative
power of faith to the transformative power
of money?
Except The Almighty never promised a million
bucks in eight easy steps.
Three: what if by solemnly portraying a crowd
that worships Jordan, despite his detestable
actions, Scorsese suggests something really
sinister?
That we actually like being taken advantage
of.
“Oh, baby!
You’re gonna play rough, huh?”
French philosopher Jean-Francois Lyotard famously
said as much —
“The English unemployed did not become workers
to survive, they… enjoyed the hysterical,
masochistic, whatever exhaustion it was of
hanging on the mines, in the foundries, in
the factories, in hell, they enjoyed it…
— “Ah!
Jesus Christ!”— … enjoyed the mad destruction
of their organic bodies…
— “I like it!
I like it!” — the decomposition of their
personal identity, —“You are lower than
pond scum.” — … enjoyed the dissolution
of their families and villages, and enjoyed
the new monstrous anonymity of the suburbs
and the pubs in the morning and evening.”
So, could this closing image indicate the
voluntary submission of the masses, who not
only don’t mind white collar criminals stealing
their money, but find a perverse enjoyment
in their banal existence under the heel of
the Jordan Belforts of the world?
This one single shot is emblematic of just
how complex The Wolf of Wall Street is.
As a true totem of our culture of excess,
the film defies easy answers.
This format is a bit of a test for us, so,
let us know
what
you think in
the comments.
And as always, guys, thanks for watching.
Peace.